we're providing you with an asset drop
via the link below so you can download
the images and include them in the app
when we open up the assets zip file we
see that the same icon is provided at
different sizes for different
resolutions in the drawable mdpi folder
we see the assets that will be used on
an mdpi device in the drawable hdpi
folder we see the assets that will be
used on hdpi device and the same goes
for the other folders under the res
directory copy over all the asset
folders provided in the download
clicking on an image shows a preview of
it and the size and pixels is also shown
at this time you can also remove the old
placeholder IC Launcher icons our new
launcher icons are located in mipmap
folders these are distinct folders from
the drawable folders if you build an APK
for a target screen resolution like hdpi
the Android asset packaging tool apt can
strip out the drawables for other
resolutions that you don't need but if
it's in the MIT map folders then these
assets will stay in the APK regardless
of the target resolution but when would
you need an image at a resolution
different than the resolution of the
device well one example is the Android
launcher app which controls the home
screen as well as all apps for the
launcher app won't use the icon at the
current density of the device but rather
pulls the icon for the next highest
resolution up for an xxhdpi device like
the Nexus 5 normally the assets will be
pulled from the drawable xxhdpi folder
however in this case the launcher icon
will pull the xxx hdpi version of the
launcher icon that will make the larger
app icons appear sharper on the all apps
screen in the code replace a drawable ic
launcher with app mipmap IC launcher
because of the new location of the icons
for the rest of the icons modify the
forecast list and the detail screen to
display the right weather icon instead
of the placeholder one see the hints
below in the instructor notes using the
helper functions we've provided in the
gist below you can map the weather
condition code to the icon that you'll
need this is what the app should look
like when you're done with this step
note that there are two types of each
weather icon a gray icon and a colored
art image
and the main forecast list will be using
the grey icon however for the today
layout will use the colored icon when
you go inside the detail activity you'll
also use the colored icon at this time
you can also remove any images you
hard-coded into the layout XML because
they'll be populated dynamically now